I see you.
What? I'm scratching.
Hey, Mom.
Is it okay if I have a friend
come over tomorrow?
Who? Rueben?
Or the nervous one
that gets the nose bleed?
It's Griffin Cooper.
Griffin Cooper.
Griffin Cooper is by far
the coolest kid in Manny's grade.
Hes’s a terrific athlete.
Confident.
Manny’s a great kid. Sure,
But he's not exactly cool.
He can't even open a door cool.
Salutations, Wyatt.
I'm so glad you're joining me
for an afternoon of mirth.
Good evening, Reuben. Son.
May I ask you to remove your shoes
tonight?
We are going Japanese.
Oh, he will love you.
Will ballet Lei move by rumble?
I invented a new language this morning.
When did you guys become buddies
with a football game in the yard?
You made a great catch? No,
that didn't happen.
But the librarian told me
one day I'll be a great catch.
I'm really not getting that relationship.
Why can't you just be happy
the manny is making new friends.
Because it doesn't add up.
Cool kids like Griffin Cooper,
they don't hang out with kids like Manny.
Manny is very cool.
Maybe those kids are finally catching up
to him.
I get it.
Couple of days last week,
I took Manny to school on my motorcycle.
Griffin must think I'm pretty boss. Yes.
It's all because of you.
Kids are looking for role models.
Why do you think Fonzie was so popular?
He told people that they were rich, but
really took their money with his scheme.
No, that's a--
Yes.
Those people were victims
of a Fonzi scheme.
I got it.
Remember, pal, keep it simple.
Hey, Manny.
Griffin.
Legendary creature of Greek mythology
with the head of a lion
and wings of an eagle.
What do you say, Jay?
Nevermind.
Jay Pritchett.
Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you, too.
You know, I.
I saw a little basketball game of yours
last week.
You were lighting it up.
Thanks. I was lighting it up too, Jay.
Who's hot?
We're hot.
Mustangs are hot.
Oh, hey.
Hola, Griffin.
How are you?
Oh 13.
I'm fine.
So, what do you boys have planned
for today?
Well, it's kind of a surprise for Griffin
But lets just say it involves,
decoupage.
Oh, jeeze.
Come on, let’s go.
Goodbye.
Oh, no.
What?
You were right.
This boy is not here to see Manny.
I told you.
You see the way he looks at me?
No, Fonzie.
The way he looks at me!
He couldn't talk. He kept staring.
He was just like
my teacher's back in school.
You're very pretty.
But the kid idolizes me.
Really?
Griffin, Manny,
Do you want to go with Jay
to his motorcycle or
you want to go with me to the supermarket?
Then buy a couple of onions.
Motorcycle rides.
Onions sound good.
Guess he has a thing for you too.
Oh, thank you.
Hey, Mom. Guess what?
Griffin invited this all over to his house
for a pool party and barbecue tonight.
Pool party, huh? Yeah.
And he said, bring your swimsuits.
He was pretty adamant about it.
It's 50 degrees outside.
Sounds fun.
Great. I'll call him.
You know, you're basically agreeing
to a date with a 13 year old boy.
We use this to get us tables at restaurants.
Why can’t we use this to get Manny a friend?
Because he's
not really getting a friend.
But when you thought that he was trying
to ride a motorcycle, he was okay.
Maybe now I don't like what
he's trying to ride.
Manny likes Griffin, maybe someday
they spend enough time together,
Griffin would like Manny.
What?
Griffin doesn't like me?
No, no, no, Pappi. He loves you.
But you just said someday
Griffin will like me.
That means, he doesn't like
me now.
You know what kid,
we think that Griffin,
might be hanging out with you
because he's got a little crush
on your mother and me. And you?
Wow. Can't believe it. Listen, it's fine.
You're going to be sorry.
Are you kidding? It's fantastic.
How is it? Fantastic.
I'm only hanging out with him because
I have the hots for his sister, Chloe.
You've met Griffin. The kid's a doorknob.
So you're just using him?
Yeah, and I felt really guilty about it
until now.
Now it's a win win. Not for me.
Just suck it up, Mom.
I've done a lot for you over the years.
Jay, you too. This girl could be the one and
than I'm out of your hair forever.
Pool party mom.
Dress accordingly.